Hello the internet, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're the Slow Mo Guys.
One of my favorite channels,
very high production value,
Corridor Digital.
I like it.
It's a good channel, even
their second channel's good,
so what I'm gonna do is just
nick one of their ideas.
At least you're being up front about it.
Yeah, I saw them try and
slice an arrow in half
with a katana, and it looked pretty cool
at sort of medium slow mo.
So I figured why don't
we just super slow mo?
Yeah.
I'm gonna have to be firing the arrow,
you're gonna have to do the chopping.
Yeah, how do you feel that.
I've just preset the Phantom.
I dunno, I feel like I did
archery at Beavers or something.
Beavers.
Oh, are you gonna fire
one off now, really?
Yeah.
Alright, okay.
Oh, God.
You've already.
Alright.
Oh, that is gone.
That goes at some clip, that.
I sort of lost my confidence
in you being able to do it now.
Oh, really?
Well I don't really have any control,
other than, I guess I
could do some micro pulls.
But really, once it's locked in,
that's like a set speed isn't it?
Yeah.
You have to aim that nicely
so I can actually hit it,
'cause otherwise I'm gonna be
just going collecting arrows.
How many attempts do
you think it'll take you
to sever it right in
the middle of the arrow?
Clean, clean cut?
Yeah.
I reckon like 30 times.
And how many arrows do we have?
We've got six.
Yeah, I kind of didn't really
think about it that much.
Just get one, one arrow.
Yeah right, you know if I
miss it, it won't break.
Alright, let's set up the Phantom
and start what could
be a very long process
of trying to get this shot.
Alright.
Okay, so we're gonna do a few things,
because there's no one on the Phantom,
I'm gonna have the trigger
on a wire in my pocket.
And just so Dan doesn't get
skewered through the guts,
these are sort of
rubber-tipped training arrows
that would probably hurt
but not go into Dan.
Alright Dan, goggles on, gloves on.
Yep.
You think you can hit the target?
I don't know about that.
Okay, let's see.
Flipping heck.
That really goes in and all.
Don't hit me with that thing.
I'll try not to.
Okay.
Alright.
If you get it on the first attempt,
you'll save us all a lot of time.
Yeah.
I'm off-screen because I need to be
far enough away that Dan can see.
Alright I'm gonna count you down, though.
Hoo, this is gonna be hard
work, I can tell already.
Three, two, one, fire.
I got it!
I got it, trigger!
I got it.
What?
I nailed it!
I got the front.
You got the front?
What?
I got it.
Wait.
I got it!
I got it, clean.
Wait.
I got it clean.
What?
Did I get it?
Alright, pack it up.
So I bought six, we needed one.
Excellent, there we go.
So wait, that was my test one.
That was your test one.
And then you got it on the next one.
Yeah.
I was like, got my eye in, and we're done.
I thought this would be a longer video
'cause it took the
Corridor guys a few goes.
We got here so early for this.
We have like hours left.
We could just try it
again and get a closeup.
Yeah, alright.
Oh, man.
That's delicious!
Jesus.
Either I was going to miss,
or you deflected the arrow
away from the target.
Yeah wait, so I like sliced it,
I think you weren't missing.
I think you deflected
the arrow, it bounced up,
and then the flight's kicked in again,
it stabilized, and continued
higher than the target.
We could've used real arrows
with somebody stood there.
Well I think the tip
would've still hit them.
And then the tip span and
like went in backwards.
To be fair, you did
make a nice clean sever
that would've really hurt, still.
Oh yeah, well that's true.
Sorry, like the guy behind
me who I'm like protecting
is gonna be like, "Ow,
but you cut me with this."
He would be stood there with the tip
of the arrow poking out like,
"You know what, I appreciate
it, but look at that."
People would be like,
"How did that happen?"
Like what happened?
I can't believe that.
Thanks, that's pretty good, isn't it?
Happy with that.
That was wicked.
Yeah.
So the tip landed here,
and that's how I know I got it properly,
'cause I sliced, felt a very
small amount of resistance,
and I looked around and I saw the tip.
Wow, what a clean slice.
It is, isn't it?
So this is where it hit and
then bounced off onto the floor.
Oh, this part isn't quite so clean,
and there's a small shard of it
that's come off the back there.
That part marries up with the front
and there's like a small bit of like wood
that's come off the side.
Yeah, well it also hit the ground
with a lot more force 'cause
it's still sailing away.
That's probably the chipping here,
but this second part I'm sure
that came off in the slow mo,
we can see that little
extra chip come off.
Okay, this time, for a
close up, I'm gonna try
and fire right past the
Phantom, try not to shoot it,
and then we'll try to
get a much closer shot
of you doing the exact
same thing if you can.
I'll try.
I imagine if that actually hits
me, it's gonna bloody hurt.
Yeah, bet it would.
Be a nice bruise.
I've gotta just trust you here, alright?
Yeah, alright, ready?
Yeah.
Three, two, one, fire.
Got it!
Oh, I got the back of it.
You got it?
I got the back of it.
You know what, I'm
actually slightly worried
at how close to the lens I put that.
I must've missed that by a few inches.
Eyes on the arrow.
Eyes on the prize.
Oh.
See that one, it floats still by.
Guy still got it to the gut.
At least he didn't get it to the shoulder.
That was actually really nice positioning
of where that hit, because all
the feathers are coming off.
Oh yeah!
There's like loads of actual feathers
just like splintered everywhere.
What you need is directly in the middle,
and hopefully, just like in Armageddon,
they'll miss the target just like
that asteroid missed the Earth.
We've got two hours left,
I think you're asking a bit much here.
Alright, the weather's taken a turn,
we're losing light, we might
get rained on in a bit,
but before that happens,
let's try and get one more.
Same angle, I like that angle.
Okay.
Just try and get a more central hit.
I know it's asking a lot.
Alright, I'll try.
Three, two, one, fire.
Got it!
Got the end again.
Damn it.
How much time do you think distance-wise
there is between there and there?
Time?
Time.
Point zero zero something of a second.
So it seems like I'm miles out,
but I'm point bugger all away.
Yeah, I would say that the difference
between here and here could
be measured in milliseconds.
Probably.
It's going pretty fast,
we could probably calculate how quickly.
Bloody fast, yeah.
How quick that is.
We can calculate on the wide.
Yeah.
Three, two, one, fire!
I got it at the back again, damn it.
Oh, that was a really nasty cut.
Was it?
Yeah.
I sliced it really finely there.
How was it?
Oh, it was a pretty nasty splinter,
but I think you saved the bloke.
Did I?
You made it so that each end of the arrow
sort of hit him flat.
And the top half deviated away.
Well, we ran out of arrows quite quickly
because you were so damn
good at getting them.
I mean, I got them from the beginning
and sort of the middle, and the end.
I'd like to think that
you could stand behind me
on a battlefield and be alright.
Yeah I would stand behind you.
Yeah?
Yeah, I would probably
take it instead of here,
I'd take it like here and here.
It was interesting the way
that the further forward
you hit on the arrow, it would
always deviate the arrow,
but if there was enough of the arrow left,
the feathers could still
cause the rifling to the point
where it would just stabilize
again on a different path.
Also because of the weight of
the arrows is at the front,
the further forward the slice
was the cleaner the cut,
because obviously the
weight is behind the cut,
whereas there's less weight behind the cut
and it's sort of easily moveable
so it's gonna be much less.
They were much more splintery.
Yeah.
And sort of long cuts at the back.
Yeah if you see the comparison there
between the front and the back.
So we pretty much can't film anymore,
because A, we're out of arrows,
and B, there's a big old storm rolling in
that's about to blow all
of our equipment away.
Well that's not the only reason.
There is a C.
There's a reason C as to
why we're stopping filming.
I sort of shot the monitor.
You destroyed the monitor
for the slow mo camera,
so we can't actually shoot anymore.
That's the big reason why we can't shoot.
It's 'cause you hit it with an arrow.
I'm so upset.
We've got a full video
on the monitor carnage
over on our second channel so
make sure you check that out.
If you like seeing things
that are expensive and useful destroyed.
We just don't usually break equipment
on this channel, surprisingly.
Surprisingly, it's very rare.
I think that's the first loss of equipment
since the classic Go Pro cannon incident.
Wait that means we're even.
One all.
But mine was a Go Pro, and yours was that.
Mine was a several thousand
dollar small HD monitor.
Yeah.
Damn it.
Alright, make sure you go
and check out the video
over there, because we need
to buy a new monitor now.
Yeah, subscribe and watch loads of videos.
Subscribe, hit the
bell, tell nine friends.
We need to fund a new monitor.
Guys, they broke some equipment.
Alright, thank you very much for watching,
we'll see you in the next video.
Love and kisses.
Think I was born in the wrong time.
You would've been an excellent
Japanese man from the past.